Ron Binion: And ...
Narrator: In this shot from
"Ghostbusters: Afterlife,"
a Terror Dog stomps on Paul Rudd's car.
But that's not CGI.
It's actually a puppeteer
wearing a mechanical Terror Dog arm
controlled by a series of cables.
To make creatures like the Terror Dog
and this ghoulish skeleton
hyperrealistic, makeup effects teams
have to juggle visual design,
classic puppeteering, and animatronics.
Bill Sturgeon: Instead of being an actor
and giving a performance,
it's getting nine people
to get a performance.
Narrator: Making practical creatures
look hyperrealistic
requires plenty of trial and
error in the design phase.
This was especially true for "Afterlife."
To stick to the spirit of
the original "Ghostbusters,"
the team had to modernize the
original Terror Dog from 1984
with as little CGI as possible.
They started with these maquettes,
miniature models used to
nail down a creature's look
before creating the
actual on-screen model.
Maquettes also give
the visual effects team
a real-life reference so
they can complete CG shots
that are too difficult to do practically,
like when the Terror Dog
runs through Walmart.
This is when Arjen runs
paint tests on a mock head
to determine which colors
look best on camera.
For example, his team
amped up the lip color
in the final version.
And a more detailed
reference head gives a sense
of what it'll look like
under movie lighting.
Arjen: So if he's in warm light,
you can tell he is more brown,
but if he's in cooler
light, he's more gray.
Narrator: At the same time,
"Afterlife" animatronic
designer Bill Sturgeon
conducted a movement test
by connecting a scaled-down 2D printout
of the Terror Dog to brass tubing,
a Popsicle stick, and plastic cables.
This is how Sturgeon determines
the creature's biggest
and most notable movement,
known as the gross body move.
Once a creature's look and
movements are solidified,
the makeup effects team will then
sculpt the final design true to size.
For "Afterlife," they made
a larger model of the dog
out of 600 pounds of clay,
which served as the mold
for the actual animatronic.
So it was key to get everything
right, down to the crevices
on its horns and skin.
Arjen cast the mold with foam latex,
a departure from the modern
standard of silicone.
We opted to go with foam
latex because of the weight,
but it also moves great in compression.
Silicone would have worked,
but it also would have made the Terror Dog
about 500 pounds heavier
than it already is.
Narrator: With the mechanics
and protective fiberglass shell,
the Terror Dog ultimately
weighed 450 pounds --
still heavy, but light enough to maneuver.
Softer foam latex
wouldn't suffice for every
part of the creature,
like its teeth, which
were made with acrylic.
Arjen: So they're actually hard. Yeah.
You not want to get
bitten by one of these.
Narrator: The acrylic created
a degree of translucency,
similar to a real set of teeth,
but it would be too brittle
for the dog's nails,
which needed to be strong enough
to endure the physical
demands of shooting.
So they used a urethane resin
for light, tough, and hollow nails.
Arjen: If they would get hit,
or somebody would accidentally step on it,
they wouldn't break.
So there's a lot of
thought that went into it.
Narrator: These horns were also made
of the same resin as the nails,
which let light in to look
more realistic on camera.
Look at the difference
between the horns made during paint tests
and the final version.
It just absorbs the light
like a real horn would.
Narrator: The horns also
needed to be sturdy,
since they needed to be removable.
The crew only made one
Terror Dog animatronic
to stand in for both
Zuul and Vinz Clortho,
so they built the horns
with magnetic attachments,
which could easily be swapped out.
These longer horns were for the male,
and these shorter ones were
for the female Terror Dog.
But for practical creatures
to look convincing,
they ultimately have
to move realistically.
Unlike more traditional puppeteering,
animatronic work requires
mechanized motors
known as servos,
which can be programmed to
create specific movements.
Instead of cables and strings,
they're brought to life using controllers.
For "Afterlife,"
the Terror Dog would have to be designed
to fit all the servos inside.
And there were a lot of them.
The Terror Dog had 21
servos in its face alone
to allow for subtle expressions.
And one mouth movement
could take three people to perform it.
Bill: Because the mouth is so big,
the servos have to move a lot of material
to make it look right.
Narrator: For example, the
servos needed the ability
to rotate and move a lot of skin around
for subtle movements such as blinking,
squinting, and sniffing.
So the foam latex was much
thinner in the face and neck
than the body.
Bill: If you know a part's going to move
more than something else, you
might make deeper wrinkles.
Narrator: You can see
that feature in the neck,
which Arjen knew would be heavily
utilized, and gave Sturgeon
the ability to imitate a
very specific head turn
the original puppet did in 1984.
It could even look like it was actually
eating out of a bag of dog
food during this moment.
The Terror Dog also needed
to open its mouth wide,
meaning placement of the jaw's
pivot point was also key.
Arjen: We had to figure
that it can't be too high,
can't be too low. It would look odd.
Narrator: Going down the rest
of the animatronic's body,
the foam latex could be much thicker,
since it had less animatronic movement.
But it still required
some crucial additions.
Sturgeon placed a linear
actuator in the beast's stomach.
This specific servo would only
push out in a straight line
to mimic realistic breathing.
This full-body shot of
the Terror Dog right here,
that's actually CGI, as Arjen and his team
never created its back half for real.
Instead, the top half
was attached to a cart
with two weights on it.
The cart made it easier to
move the heavy puppet around
so it could be placed on the
hood of a car in one shot.
Puppeteers will also rely
on traditional cables
when the movement calls for it.
Like with this snarl, one of
the most complicated movements
for the dog.
Sturgeon used cables to work alongside
the servos in the lips
to really nail the look.
Bill: That's actually a number of servos
working at the same time
to give it a left and a
right side, and a snarl.
Narrator: And in these quick
shots of a skeleton miner,
the ghosts needed to handle a coffee mug.
So creature designer Tanner
White designed this cable system
that connected his hand
to the miner's hand.
Tanner: Each of the
joints was the real limit
of the actual hand joint.
So it didn't move when it shouldn't.
So each finger correlates
to the finger movement.
And since you use your own hand strength,
you can grasp things a lot stronger
than you could with a radio control.
To grip something like the cup here,
basically you just pull all the fingers
and the wrist movement
down so that he's grasping,
and then if you let go? He drops it.
Narrator: Giving life to these creatures
can mean some very uncomfortable positions
for the puppeteers.
While the miner's eyes were
radio-controlled off-camera,
Arjen had the cable operate
its brows and other parts
of its face through the
bottom of the puppet.
That meant crouching
under the diner counter
to avoid ending up on camera.
For some moves, it's
easier just to puppeteer
a single part of the anatomy on its own
based on what's shown on camera.
Like in the close-up shot
where the Terror Dog stomps its foot down
on the hood of Rudd's car.
To get the full force,
Arjen created a separate
Terror Dog leg made of
the exact same materials.
Puppeteer Ron Binion grabbed
onto a metal armature
inside the leg to move it.
But the leg was so big
that a human arm couldn't reach the foot.
So cables were used to give
convincing ankle and toe movements.
Ron: When I'm moving it, I want to move it
in arcs that are similar to
what the Terror Dog would do.
On the day of shooting,
I was up pretty high,
same way, and trying to
get myself out of the shot.
I'm looking at a spot on the
car hood, where I'm aiming,
but also trying to keep
myself out of the frame.
And ...
If I'm pushing down,
you can still see the foot
adjusting and moving and flexing
as the creature would be,
shifting on its weight
and sort of coming down hard.
Narrator: And just like an
actor, a practical creature
needs some makeup before
being camera-ready.
That can be as simple as a
glossy shine on the skin,
or some drool.
So the crew applied a
product called UltraSlime
to the dog's lips on set.
Arjen: So we would do
this just before the take
and set it.
So in other words, if
he would start moving,
it would string and start stretching.
And you can see it just starts dripping,
but you've got to catch
it at the right moment,
but that's the fun part about it.
The actors loved it.
I remember Paul Rudd jumping up and down.
And Carrie being so,
so happy to see something
physically on set,
which is so rare these days.